whereas the bathroom is downstairs
downstairs yeah yeah and it's good for
both there's a yes there's both okay hey
everyone welcome to the other show we're
talking about episode 8 today and we are
joined by drew and Elena as always and
Josh cigar who plays Lance is really
gonna like it I know you guys knew each
other we've known each other for like a
decade yeah not super close but man
we've been buddies ever since man just
from the theater world right show has so
many Broadway people really trained
Pedro you saw Angels in America part one
did you see the second part I still
haven't seen still hasn't seen it as if
it's running and it's a possibility sex
there's a weird thing we just remembered
is that you auditioned for like a
thousand different roles didn't you
actors remember you Kimmy now that it
worked out this way yeah for sure I read
three different parts I kept going up
uh-huh it was a flight attendant then it
was the roommate and that was hilarious
because now I know what happens and
that's super fun and then they said hey
man you want to come play with this one
I said we basically had to like make it
fit you better so we like spend a little
time with you
it started hearing the words you said
like oh hell yeah your voice kind of
like became part of the character which
is why even lying
cameras here because we all know that
Lance is your spirit animal inside of
you for years she wants that one night
and saying can you say oh hell yeah here
and give it absolutely not not drinking
alcohol tonight you're 14 plus you're
contractually obligated to drink boss
so in Orlando where I grew up for many
years we went to this resort so I
remember it's either my 13th or 14th and
I remember men just beautiful men in
speedos
I remember this pool will be like this
is the pass in arcade they had wrestle
fest the video game that an indoor pool
outdoor pool but men so we go to the top
of the slide and I meet two men gorgeous
men and I say guys what's going on here
man and it's the first time I learned
what pride was pride is the weekend of
June and they were holding pride at that
resort and I was also having my birthday
party for view into pride right cool
with the slide arcade the best friends
Wow
we grew up differently yeah I could feel
it
this is the episode where these two
characters reconnect Brooke and Lance
and we really when we were writing it we
were just kind of like what are well
almost like leaning into the wrong
calmness of it a little bit of like
where these are what are these iconic
places we can put them in one of them
was on the bridge on the Brooklyn Bridge
and so we got to shoot we had to like
shut down part of small part of the
bridge and like redirect tourists who
were very eager to see who was shooting
and then like filming people would come
up to me and be like who's filming over
there it's me
to take it down you sort of think like
oh I want to be on a TV show and then
you're closing off parts of the Brooklyn
Bridge you're there waiting for the Sun
to go down and you're like whoa it was
crazy that was such a special like that
scene watching those characters have
separated from each other you you
watched him help your little brother and
that is like I think something a lot of
us gonna relate to with like past
relationships as they become a part of
your family yeah well it's like you I
think that she thought that her life was
gonna be this big thing and then she you
know is faced with this person who was a
part of it and she's like I don't I I
don't need this and then realizes how
important those like simple things are
and that kind of a connection and not to
be too dramatic because this is a comedy
thing but we did talk about because we
both have a parent who died and we
talked about relating to having an ex
that knew our parent and then being like
we are we're breaking up with them but
you still feel a connection because
you're like they knew so we kind of like
that about your character in the season
that you're introduced as sort of like a
dummy or introduced as a comic relief or
as like a this guy but kind of
humanizing him throughout and seeing
that he is like a solid person he's like
a rock and he is like he's like his
mom's friends Connie and you know yeah
in the middle of laughter you see two
people connect you know taking care of
their younger brother you know like you
know it's very easy to kind of stay on
the surface of stuff but you get down to
it that's
this thing is cool that's one kind be to
be here
[Music]
you